hey guys how's it going welcome back to
my fun-filled Valentine's festivities
cooking baking whatever you want to call
it today we're going to make some heart
brownies and this is basically just like
making normal brownies but in a
heart-shaped pan so really it's not that
difficult so we think I've got all of
our items prepared I'm also going to
throw in some chocolate chip cookies
because why not we're going to put in
our water 1/4 cup oil - 3 let me just
simplify 2/3 2/3 2/3 half like I'm not
usually about that measuring life today
we're measuring in yesterday and
probably tomorrow alert as well it's
funny because when you measure stuff it
actually works out pretty well kind of
crazy how that works out I can send you
my egg first oh shoot
[Music]
I know what there's something metal
let's put in our brownie mix just like
so
and when you put in our chocolate chips
tap this bag is gold all the chocolates
at Mindy's after these are gone because
the other day I really wanted to
chocolate I have any chocolate at my
house so I broke into my stash the stash
of chocolate so pops you little piece of
ancient lock and load
let's roll
we ain't got time or nothing that's so
fast that will cut off your entire arm
looks like some delicious brownie batter
to me
all right make sure you grease up your
pan real good real nice now we're going
to fill it up
Cheryl use a soup ladle whatever the
heck this is and you go little tasty
yummy brownie mix oh did you see that
impeccable impeccable timing oh shoot
man that I'm here man
[Music]
she only made a little tiny mess but our
brownies are placed neatly into our
little heart-shaped brownie pan cupcake
tin whatever it is let's put them in the
oven
this looks a list by and by the magic of
editing you guys didn't have to sit
around while these bake so here we are
we have our beautiful little cupcakes I
might have dropped one so we're down
brownie but here they are they look
pretty good
I'm not sure which side I'm going to
want to decorate we've got this one side
it has a little indented heart and this
one has like Krusty's on it so we can do
a little bit of both I've got some
random items I've got some heart-shaped
marshmallows so happy from candy mouth
which is basically a small tiny version
of big candy melt bags when I had used
before so I don't know what we're going
to spin it let's just touch it decorate
let's start with our first little
cupcake does not cupcakes the brownies
you know what I mean
good this looks good this is fun Betty
vanilla marshmallow icing hello oh yeah
nothing says I love you like funfetti
marshmallow icing on a brownie it's
shaped like a heart
you can use microwavable drizzle pouch I
guess I hope it's in the microwave power
setting one minute 50 plug
I thought it'd be nice to write a little
something on this part
you
oh yeah that great work continues to
surprise what if I doesn't know clearly
the funds can be drizzle two in the bag
this is a really nice decoration all
their little icing hearts these are cute
well maybe need resting on it then uh
how about this marshmallow stuff like it
tastes really good but it doesn't really
go on very well so you might want to
reconsider so it can be seen anything
more beautiful didn't think so yeah I
will definitely be saving one of these
for myself
ah you know what I should do I should
use one of my Kiwis that I made from a
previous video oh nothing says I love
you like a chocolate - oh it's credible
like anything's coming out put a little
look how pretty
ease me what can I eat look at this that
looks better I have a poop yes tell me
what you think of it that looks much
better
I don't I don't know you be nice follow
up okay good I just want to make this
super festive little brownie Dobis seem
to add a few of those on the other looks
good
whatever how is this gonna work I'm
hoping it works well yeah I don't know
if that's gonna be drizzling anything
that's look at a drizzle that's not as
advertised
like that's not a drizzle that's a
freaking turd that's a pink - we got to
put some reason the little oil flakes
new little meltdown give it a real nice
drink it's not working why are you not
working that's what I was going for yes
that's it
yeah it's beautiful real good look I
guess I'll just use my little
marshmallows now and the strawberry
flavored this is a very good let's put
one of the hearts on that we made
another video that looks good
some silver sprinkles you don't want to
look where I'm getting this stuff from I
just kind of stock up on random baking
supplies and things that look cool and
hope in one day I will use them so here
we are this is the haze here I mean
these are back from whatever row and I
did that noob cake challenge two years
ago it was very colorful cake I don't
know if somebody would ever request this
kind of cake for their birthday well but
it's made with a lot of love and
creativity so maybe we would now they're
going to for sure
okay guys do they are these are looking
oh boy oh boy
if you maybe for anybody they would be
like wow you are talented and perfect
and probably in love with Netflix
the soup can look how good
come here alright good that one's my
favorite one
pinky Omer that one alright guys thank
you so much for watching this is our
final outcome I'm honestly beside myself
like if I'm here and if I could just
duplicate myself for me right here so I
got impressed if I ask myself what do
you think if you guys say they're great
[Music]
smart I'll have another fun Valentine's
video for you guys and then who knows
what else I'll be posting throughout the
week but stay tuned for that I'm excited
to eat one of these okay I don't even
know if women would eat meat probably
the network's Lauren's let me know which
one your favorite is if you guys decide
to make any heart brownies uh feel free
to send me your decorations and I'm sure
they'll be you know better than mine
because you guys always make things
better smooth I'll see you guys next
video five
[Music]
sensitive on synagogue so many many
hours later we're back and we've got our
delicious two candies are delicious
beautiful heart and we're going to pop
them out of these molds and see what we
can see oh wow